[Applause]
[Music]
it's mother flipping in the white time
roll the intro leave your memes on the
reddit nineteen-year-old measure upp so
WI why it's Coco melon still beating me
I've done everything I can
why am I still getting PP I will have to
do the one thing I didn't have think I
have do review memes on the Internet
okay let's go this is a very
uncomfortable posture but I'll commit to
it when you brought so much pity primers
that G feel sends you 48 cans of the new
unreleased beauty by flavor
hell yeah that's dope that they did that
that's really cool
round of applause for GPU you definitely
deserved name I hope you like the flavor
actually they officially sent you more
GPS than me they send me two packs you
got put in four that's okay you deserve
it oh man's even got ones in the back
what the hell how much do they send you
48 Kenz
I can read yeah I can't read ah yes me
my husband and his towering pillar of
tambourines every milli Tamborine goes
nothing rhymes with merely goddammit
bigger a little e come on I want to see
it reach the moon we can get it come on
come o agent e oh okay is that supposed
to be me hey where's that guy
[Music]
hey that's that yeah a lot of bells are
cried those in bounce dr. big BP New
York Times knives this is in every
episode of finis infer basically well
bad huge humongous dick I'm just gonna
call it for what it is I'm just kidding
oh my god I met the meme guy at the
airport it looks like a guy in his
toddler how tall is this guy cuz he's
probably my it looks like he's my hi
judging from the background and people
yeah I'd say we're the same height
looking at the size of that can and
Felix open crunchyroll to watch enemy me
you should open crunchyroll so you can
watch all your videos you just had to
dig that up then yeah hey I don't care
animes epic can't change my mind hate us
watching fruit wars
it's epic they orgasm over eating food
that's every fruit have fruit worse
that's what it should be this is what
this is fruit works out oh my god this
panel is amazing are your wedding send
very cool huge dick happy Father's Day
to everyone who was like a perfect happy
Father's Day that has already passed
five days ago but still happy Father's
Day
oh my god I missed Father's Day spend it
in him and celebrate cringe here sigh
put your me me this is a good definitely
we didn't think of that
sigh redemption put something at bay and
then make a remix I and
make a full feature-length film Syme
banks I you're the best
no you can't make a meme on the street
ha ha chalk go screw I'm glad this means
Saints living it's a good one
sighs editing mr. beast gaming channel
his own channel and pity Christ channel
how you doing sighs you holding up now
make a trilogy feature film about memes
I expect that in this video side oh my
god that looks beautiful there was
another woman like this in the last Last
of Us stream it was really funny I wish
I could say this was Jesus Christ even
the shoulder our wedding said yes the
video posh at a really epic moment of
course I'm winning name a character that
went through more pain than her I'll
wait on Punjab candidate cries after
getting off why do I keep saying it's
funny I want to say it's funny shut up
okay I save it's funny
PD PI I'm sort of a genius also
PewDiePie poor lion I keep telling you
guys I'm smart dumb it's a thing look it
up if it's not a thing yeah I should
make it a thing yes yes this is what I'm
talking about that's the floor the true
floor on the chair as well damn hey
clutch chairs we should make that
Tamborine chair never done before it
sounds like a mr. beast video tambourine
chair is real the only way to be floor
again oh I should do that
I should modify my clutch chair okay
when once quarantine over and I go back
you know it's gonna happen oh we got
another intro
[Applause]
[Music]
my stand aside very nice I love you guys
keep delivering on these we get an
amazing one each time all right here's
another one all right so I'm not gonna
have a new one to put on this one okay
no I mean yes that's right Coco you get
where you freakin deserve are we doing
on the subs
we're losing great SOB's guys I don't
have enough subscribers guys please this
is serious
hashtag unsubscribe t-series trending it
in India blue shirt kid happy
nine-year-old noises yeah I haven't
really followed this but I've seen
people talk about it and there was
something about yeah sushant singh
rajput I didn't say that name properly
it was I think it was a university talk
of this guy and he seemed like such a
good dude like a genuinely good dude so
people were pointing to nepotism in the
industry and then that's somehow it got
it clashed with teachers and that's why
under sub from t-series I got trending
like I'm I'm past all I said I don't
want to make a whole thing like oh look
unsub haha but it's just a shame he he
he decided to end his life because I
mean I don't know everything about him
but from what I saw he seemed like a
really good dude and someone that the
industry needs so it's a huge loss rest
in peace
Felix you have been more of a father to
me than my actual father he never raised
me my mom did but you helped me learn
comedy humbleness compassion how to
conduct myself and wisdom you are truly
the uncle Iroh to people who have crappy
dads
oh that's so sad but made me so happy
there it is we can contrast it with this
very nice it's onions in here there's
onion in the air I'm watching fruit Wars
onion makes meat break down the flavors
I know about it
oh ok yes dad I am Haitian dad it was
like a father to me
hey for you who don't have a dad are you
winning Stan I watching PewDiePie he's
like a father to me
move YouTube channel Coco melon to
YouTube kids I mean it I'm not saying
this out of oh I as a tactic to beat
them but it always baffled me because it
clearly is in a different category I
don't really understand I don't
understand it either I'm just confused
by it only 250 people come on this took
way longer than he should have been all
right what is it oh that's gonna
collapse isn't it oh cool alright let's
see it
whoa it's like dominoes in Minecraft
that's so cool yeah brah I miss mine
Kratt very cool very very cool wholesome
reddit moment right there a lot of
wholesome ready moments today yeah I'll
play minecraft soon again I just want to
finish last of us you know I need a
reason to come back to Minecraft
defeating Andrew dragon with Jack nether
update release adventure maps' Skyblock
I'm like of like sky blood I already
beat it Sven's birthday minecraft
emergency apart to defeat the Ender
Dragon with Jack is something yeah I
want to really do but I already checked
out the nether update adventure maps are
laying sky block I already beaten son's
birthday is a given and minecraft we
might say yeah maybe okay
oh my god
[Laughter]
you and the council king of tambourines
Mima wizard god damn you guys are so
talented so cool well done e to survival
10 out of 10 I want the time we're in
larger please subscribe it doesn't
matter if we have house of diamonds or
dirt or emeralds we all have the same
size baby my mind blowed thank you so
much what's her name Elliott Billy
Elliott be really Bill eyelash thank you
and have a gold Nadia oh that's another
trick to get a get a girl you you say
you like bread you win the yo-yo
championship tournament and you tell
them you got gold you're in that's it
you got a cake in the oven five ten
girls five ten guides this is truly a
mean template well done well done for
this photo fresh because this is not
YouTube kids YouTube de monetize his
videos Delphine the softcore porno
YouTube I'm gonna pretend I didn't see
that no they they age-restricted the
video to be fair with YouTube they
definitely do monetize then PewDiePie
intro plays for the 10th time the rest
of the family me and my interests are
working keep making the intros
we are converting the infants we're
expanding our demographic Finn isn't
freb our geniuses
so is dr. Doofenshmirtz their mother
used to date that what what oh my god
faders and found nah they do have a
similar oh my god I cannot watch fit
it's a verb the same way it's all one
giant big love triangle we should donate
to Wikipedia instead of twitch time and
that's a fact have you donated to
Wikipedia say it honestly cuz I have
that's right I'm a better person
you now go donate Rick seelix I don't
have it
okay I get you're not a good person all
right and here's the clown here's the
rhyme see a planner
no one sims for me this is so sad crying
emoji motion it scares me but this one I
can deal with very nice brother made
side white and an alternate universe
volume - oh my god there's so many good
interests hold on she says all right now
we're give the kids nightmares this is
all part of the plan
part of the plan we convert the infants
and then we terrify them into staying
subscribe subscribe infants or I will
reveal that Santa isn't real this has
been the first warning we did it we
time-traveled but - what year let me ask
that guy over there
it's tuber similar still relevant of
course it is I have no idea dude Beach
update is out check it out work on your
beach bond while playing the beach but
update oh no what happened there stop
giving me nightmares please
the quality is getting better I tried my
best while you drive your bass so I will
have to commend this
oh yeah cuz I keep forgetting I can hand
these out right Felix chosen done yeah
there's a couple others I want to
actually reward this one as well so I
get this one gets a tambourine oh my god
holding glorious pbthe ivory with help
of Edgar's legs damn Edgar don't skip
out on leg day goddamn okay this is the
latest theory that Edgar is my legs
because there was a photo leaked of me
we don't have to talk about the photo
it's all good it's all good
happy Father's Day to everyone who was
like a father to show him when he was a
father to me a year ago it was night
when the hero was born oh yeah that
takes me back
god damn adventures in video games man
you can actually have memories in video
games that's from video games that's
awesome
damn that's I'm having a lot of fun you
guys are so cool this guy it looks like
he could be everyone's best friend
everyone needs a pal like this and you
know it that's a big chunk of wholesome
rated moment right there nah but Bally
this teaser is kids all right we need a
pity pie kids channel we need to fight
fire with fire goddamn it who wants to
run it I need help
um what you got there a smoothie why is
this meme still going hey I'll take it
who has remember 2002 yeah okay I look
like Shaggy good good do I look like
shaggy now I don't think so damn the
light keeps changing so much on this
boom
[Music]
oh good camera I know Terry are you
reading a book yeah dude it's called the
art of seduction
later hey Isaac I baked bread hey I know
you didn't care about the yo-yo
tournament championship without make red
god damn it
he likes to be that so quirky and love
him so I'm reaching watching kids Mike
have let's play as I decided it as I
watched it last year and decided to
remind you about some side character you
would not exist
oh right what happened to the tree I
don't even it must be somewhere all
right a thing to investigate when I
return to Minecraft the big return
Nick head chin good good when Felix says
big PP does he mean long or thing could
be bigger if we get more subscribers of
course but yeah about that size I'm
willing to reveal the inside information
I made a curse side version they keep
making new Whiteside I can't believe it
[Music]
people don't know is Cyrus actually
Eskimo he comes from Greenland
Felix Kjellberg PewDiePie no no once I
give me hiccup no no no my sister named
in Twitter ends with shell Berg but her
username ends with PI the sign means she
is married to both Felix Kjellberg and
Peter pie huh sorry that was great mean
template great memes today guys well
done beauty part
what is your wisdom everyone's afraid to
be nice because they think it's not cool
but it's cool to be nice thanks good
wisdom
thank you for cutting off what I said
right afterwards it's true though it's
true everyone one likes to be a big a
big I'm so epic up this person this
person that you don't always have to be
like that
I'm not saying um Wonder Woman I'm just
saying no I can actually read this I'm
not I'm just nobody
Wonder Woman saying I'm saying has me
ever and seen Wonder Woman in the same
room together
that's good typography these are not
even centered I don't know everyone
would say do your job I did the job but
look I did it I put the text in this
grade I broken into a house and left
50,000 it's stealing just backwards
is that what donating is wait there's a
movie oh hell yeah when we beat Coco
melon I'll wash it the ultimate whoa oh
man you get you get the ward tambourine
award there it is there it is
unsubscribe teachers training in Twitter
in India I was not expecting the hint
the plot thickens that was so funny we
take them over
glorious tambourines our broken
tambourine ooh I like that
same thing small peepee big baby a right
thing right thing right there Coco Bella
was sacrificed before it was even a
threat I knew okay
I'm extremely smart I know all things
there is yeah I like bread and that's
how I lost my virginity
I mean how I Met Your Mother yeah I miss
my zest channel not gonna lie and we're
gonna hear Felix in this video I
apologize for that boy manga any me
Netflix I don't page head I always felt
like I was most my character is most
myself feel a PewDiePie aged more like
Poehler with big baby
very nice tambourine to the same address
for the 10th time very nice Amazon
delivery guys
recognized me a lot of time so that this
seems pretty accurate although this is
ups this guy right here
super weird don't like him I don't like
him at all pretty by starting more
against t-series starting a war against
the ceilings starting working against
Kokomo starting a war against Felix
Shellback
yeah with all the people getting
cancelled nowadays it baffles me that
Felix Kjellberg has not been cancelled
that's right everyone
I'm calling Felix Kjellberg out for too
long he's gotten away with it but no
more I'm done Felix Kjellberg when he
was six years old he was not that much
into tambourines
I know Felix Kjellberg when he was seven
years old
he ain't kokum I mean he had melons
crazy times but at least we have a good
time laughing at means thanks for all
the service in this week that was great
I had a lot of fun gonna do a live
stream now right after this but you
won't know that because it already
happened but thanks for joining the
night for you thanks for all the members
thanks for staying members thanks for
staying awesome here's a breakfast
because why the hell mine brofist yeah
[Music]
it's time to race what was one forgotten
what creatures fought spells and poop
troops awaits hope tears coming to
Nintendo's wait and remember it has a
very big peepee
[Music]
jmes checkbook vernacular man